ah
I have always liked to transmit
Emotions has practically everything
it's a day in a marginalized community
and suddenly you have to go back because
there is a crocodile that is trapped in
a house
that same day in the night
an executed
anyone can kill you for writing
something or to take a picture
really know that veracruz is the state
more dangerous for journalism
in veracruz we live in a state of
simulation where it seems that there is no
violence does not want to give a face
other than mexico even
However, it is quite the opposite
they had the unit
I'm Felix Marquez photojournalist in the
state of veracruz in mexico
I am 27 years old
When I started the race, the
boom of violence in veracruz and
I started covering confrontations
shot dead and shootings and so on
that is to say what I say
was not
he does not appear shit
it's clear that a militarization
from the moment he is dismissed
a police force to enter
federal patrol is a military
militarization completely
authority is exceeded
completely for the crime
common and organized crime
many times
we all have identified that we are going to
take justice the authority has not
done nothing
they do not have a large number registered
of groups that are organizing
even in the colonies of the port of
veracruz to fight the
delinquents of the common forum that are the
that in a certain way affect the
population
in authority does not want to acknowledge that
exists in these groups I do not know why not
they like to talk about the subject of
Self-defense, however, our work
is to register it is to evidence what
a statement came from the secretary of
public safety where he said that I
I should be a prisoner
unfortunately
I have covered most murders
to journalists
the same case repeats a house
half finished with a sheet roof
with a floor of sand in the middle of a coffin
the coffin of a journalist that with the
minimum wage that we have tried
to move forward his family
I'm not this because Sanchez son of
moisés sanchez journalist murdered in 2
January 2015 in the east from very
young
you
was interested in the question of
social activism because of the question of
report
produces all the tools that
had at his command and one of them was the
Newspaper
here
next movie
the union is born from the roots of moisés sanchez
to spread stories that do not
spread in the media
co-opted by the system is the
journalism that should exist and the
ideal journalism is journalism
attached to the people
It is a medium that we are using
as a flag
but that nobody of us studied
journalism to cover
the deaths of their peers the idea of
this
to make a series is to take up the
objects of journalists who have
been killed revive a bit of the
essence of who was everyone to look for
the objects and that represent who was
for example in this case moisés sánchez
help there we have a speaker that
They usually used to have a little one
that we already have it yet which is the one
then he was taking to the rally was
A) Yes
Little what my father did was
just that receiving the acts
of corruption of the police
he was exposing the
Authorities in Medellín de Bravo
they were doing their job well
some characters in politics
in the municipality in the state do not
looked like
who had already warned him that
mayor he thought to give a scare moses
was kidnapped at night in front of
his family
was murdered today the mayor says his
lawyer who is no longer in Veracruz
he has already left the state
and if there are many many anomalies in this
investigation are the same anomalies
what's in all the investigations
against journalists
where they do not investigate and they do not do their
work
after the fact happened we
they put security and if you decide to close or
not that they are the ones that
they did nothing they knew my father and
it is precisely those that amount
yes
assumes that others should be locked
people and us
but that's how it works
criminals go free and we
we have to be locked
Many people
he works to live and in truth we
it seems that we are working to die
they already told you they're going to kill because
you keep publishing and he always told me
is that you can not live with fear
If you live with fear you are never going to
change the things
and his family has been very active to
demand justice in this case and punish
the guilty
the truth
I know that it gives me that they are going to kill me
it is more than obvious
but
the other option is to stay quiet and
that this is repeated
the fight that we have is behind
of the cameras is behind the pens
is informing the truth and the
society that are really our
bosses